[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and today
at the apple event i got to see the new
iphones the iphone 6s and the iphone 6s
plus they're both coming out in late
september for the same price as the
current iphones were when they launched
so of course i took a good hard look now
as expected the design of the 6s is
pretty much the same as the 6. in fact
the only way you'll be able to tell you
have the 6s is by that little s badge on
the back of course also if you have the
new rose gold color which to my eye is
really more of like a pale pink but yeah
other than that from top to bottom all
the way around the outside of this phone
it's the same phone although the new 6s
plus is actually a little bit heavier in
the hand than the current 6 plus and i
think we can thank bengate for that
since apple is now using a 7000 series
aluminum alloy to strengthen the body
but it's only a couple extra grams so
there are three main improvements to
know about in the new iphone new specs
new cameras and new display so the spec
bump is is in the processing really so
the the 6s is rocking a new apple a9
chip which is supposedly nearly twice as
fast in the cpu and gpu performance
that's really the only spec difference
that they told us about as far as i know
it's still one gigabyte of ram still the
same non-removable battery and still
starting at 16 gigs of non-expandable
storage so everything else stayed the
same it's just adding the new a9 and the
camera in the iphone is really a bump
that got me interested in it a lot so
before the iphone had an 8 megapixel
camera as we all know this new iphone is
rocking a 12 megapixel sensor which is
awesome for a couple reasons one that
means the photos will be even crispier
and if the demo photos from the events
are any indication we may have a new
number one best smartphone camera and
number two 12 megapixels now means we
have a large enough sensor or enough
pixels for 4k video so this smartphone
is now capable of hanging with the heavy
hitters like the galaxy s6 and note 5
and lg g4 and everything pretty much
every other smartphone that's come out
this year that shoots 4k video plus the
6s also has optical image stabilization
that now works during video as well so
i'm really looking forward to testing
this camera a lot more and as a bonus
the front-facing camera also got a nice
little bump up to 5 megapixels and it
now uses the display as a dual tone
flash according to the ambient light
smart and with these new iphones you can
now turn on something called live photo
which will capture one and a half
seconds before
and after you snap the photo which is
pretty neat and you can view the live
photo by pressing down on the photo in
the gallery which brings us to our third
and final major change and that's 3d
touch not force touch
3d touch basically the same thing as
force touch so now the iphone 6s display
is pressure sensitive and to multiple
levels so you can press down a little
harder on the display to bring up a
context menu in tons of places all over
the os it's kind of like an expand
button or more info button so you can 3d
touch an icon on the home screen to
bring up some quick actions for that app
or you can press an address in a thread
to preview the location in apple maps or
you can press a thread in a messaging
app itself to preview what's in that
thread and with all these previews if
you like what you see then you can press
even harder to fully expand and bring
yourself into it or if you don't want to
then you can release the force touch and
then it shrinks itself back so it seems
like this can be useful at a level on a
smartphone it'll probably take some
getting used to the thing is i was just
playing it for a few minutes and i
started to get the hang of it and the
taptic engine in the phone is also
larger and a bit heavier and is now much
more precise so it feels more like the
force touch on the apple watch which is
impressive and it's fast i mean
obviously the whole phone will be fast
with that new a9 chip and moving around
the interface combined with swipes and
gestures i already know combining that
with the 3d touch just made it feel nice
and fast i don't know the quick tip is
with the home screen icons you can press
and then swipe over onto the action you
want to perform which was really quick
and multitasking with the 3d touch swipe
in from the left side is also pretty
quick now too so definitely a little bit
of a learning curve to get everything
down and figure out where you want to
use 3d touch
but it's promising also third party apps
can and definitely will take advantage
of this 3d touch too so there was a
couple things demoed there was a game
that can literally change weapons if you
press the display harder
there was also apps like facebook and
instagram that are already coded and
updated to take advantage of 3d touch on
the iphone 6s so there you have it it's
the new iphone the tldr is it's faster
crispier and a little more sensitive so
faster chip faster touch id faster ui
crispier for the cameras on the front
and the back and that 3d touch pressure
sensitive display it's not all super new
stuff i mean lots of it has been seen in
other smartphones before but when going
from iphone 6 to iphone 6s this is about
what i expected anyway the full review
will come when i get to use this guy as
my daily driver so let me know with a
comment what you guys want to see tested
right below that like button and i'll
get to hear your thoughts thanks for
watching i'll talk to you guys in the
next one peace